الان الى اخبار العالم الاخرى حيث قالت
وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه ان رئيس مجلس
السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان بعث برساله
خطيه الى اسماعيل عمر جيله رئيس جمهوريه
جيبوتي رئيس الدوره الحاليه للايجا ابلغه
فيها قرار حكومه السودان تجميد عضويتها في
المنظمه وارجعت الخارجيه القرار الى ما
وصفته بتجهل المنظمه لقرار السودان الذي
نقل اليها رسميا نقل اليه رسميا وقف
انخراطه وتجميد تعامله معها في اي موضوعات
تخص الوضع في السودان واوضحت الخارجيه ان
منظمه الايجاد ادرجت بندا عن السودان في
قمتها الاستثنائيه الاخيره كما حمل بيانها
الختامي عبارات تنتهك سياده السودان واشار
بيان الخارجيه الى ان حكومه السودان غير
ملزمه ولا يعنيها كل ما يصدر من ايجاد في
الشان
السوداني